foreign
[Music]
quite a funny word in some ways
um and I I want to talk about something
that is possibly more tangible but
relates to Consciousness so if we think
of morality for example it's a very
complex behavior that relates to us as
individuals and how we integrate
ourselves within the outer world so when
we study morality as neuroscientists
what we can see is that there's
particular regions particular circuits
within the brain that give rise to our
moral Behavior
and there are genes the DNA that we're
given from our mum and our dad impinge
and underpin our moral code as an
individual and there's something really
interesting that happens within our
brains as our moral codes as our moral
values get shifted there's different
changes within the stratum which is a
brain region that's involved in reward
and motivation which means that once
you've devalued your moral code and
you're transgressing then actually your
brain gets primed towards further
transgression and to receive more reward
from further transgression
so I want to start the discussion with
Consciousness by actually reducing it to
a really complex behavior of morality
I've actually done some research myself
on the neural correlates of conscious
experience so fmri study of how uh an
area Mt for example in the visual system
is correlated with our experience of
motion perception and and I think that
work is is wonderful there are now
dozens and dozens of neural correlates
with Consciousness but but the notion is
of neural correlates when we say that
they give rise to conscious experiences
that's that's more than we know we know
that they're correlated but but the idea
that they give rise is now saying we
have some theory about how exactly that
activity nmt gives rise to our conscious
experience of emotional and and that
that we don't have there are no theories
right now that can um you know all the
theories that are on the table so um
integrated information Theory
um
orchestrated collapse of microtubules
theories some Global workspace theories
if you ask the authors of these theories
and I have in person many times
can you give me a specific conscious
experience I would say integrated
information Theory what is the um
specific pattern of integrated
information that must be the taste of
chocolate and could not be the smell
over Rose or what's the integrated
information or say the neural
collapse of microtubules that must be
you know a headache and could not be the
smell of a rose and they can't give a
single one so so no scientific theory
materialist Theory Of Consciousness can
yet explain even one specific case so
it's it's they're batting zero so my
attitude is that um you know
if we don't have theories that are
physicalist that can explain this stuff
then we need to go in in a New Direction
and the work I would just say on
Evolution just to to get to the first
part of your question
basically the key idea there is that
evolution by natural selection is
governed by Fitness payoffs
and the fitness payoffs guide the
evolution of our sensory systems and so
it's a simple technical question do the
fitness payoff uh functions uh in the
guide Evolution do they have information
about the structure of objective reality
and so it's a clean technical question
doesn't matter whether you believe
evolutionary theory or not you just look
at the mathematics and and the answer is
quite clear the probability is zero that
any Fitness payoff function has any
information about any structure of
objective reality it's just that simple
so since the payoff functions don't have
that information they couldn't possibly
shape us to see the truth so that leads
to the idea that
um our perceptions are more like a a
virtual reality space and time and
physical objects are
um you know Evolution shaped us with
perceptions that guide adaptive Behavior
full stop
they didn't need to show us the truth
and they didn't show us the truth they
just got adaptive Behavior to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas